I'm topaz I'm really excited to start
today's track I see we have a lot of
amazing talks in store all throughout
the day so let's start
today's talk will take us on a journey
from the science and machine learning
Research into a working software in
production we often know where this
journey starts but we have uncertainty
regarding how and when will it end and I
know the word research it has a wide
range of meaning referring to different
things in different companies so in the
context of this talk I refer to the term
research in order to describe data
science and machine learning algorithms
throughout this talk I would use an
analogy of Mountain hiking to describe
the process of machine learning
adaptation into production and we will
make the required preparation for our
journey to start and we will face its
challenges equipped with tips and
methodologies that I will share today
the target audience while this talk is
not only aiming for managers but
basically can benefit anyone who is
engaged in AI development in any way
each can adapt the main Concepts will
describe in the day-to-day work so let's
start
first a bit my own about my own personal
Journey I'm a mother of two and my
professional Journey began in the space
industry with satellite imagery and
physical table a data continued to
electrical engineering studies in the
biomedical computer vision domain
onwards to semiconductors and inspection
and Metrology my previous role leading
algorithmic teams that develop an AI
based Sports production for live
real-time broadcasting and currently as
VP of AI at Voyage 81 in the beauty and
wellness domain so basically different
data domains different companies of
different sizes well-founded companies
corporate startups and each company at a
different stage of machine learning
adaptation maturity
and what I find in common is regardless
of companies size and data domain
whenever we embark on a new research
Journey we just face this Challenge and
you can see that I could explore here
just facing the opposite direction just
to Showcase that there is a balance for
when we wish to explore more and more uh
let's just try this one more thing I
came across this amazing paper let's
just give it a go exploration is really
important but it tends to be unbounded
and when it is it tends to drive us away
to the opposite direction from our goal
and our goal we aim for our data science
and research to actually make it into
production and meet the real world and
we don't just want to do it once we want
that to repeat and want to deliver value
again and again
and that's basically a non-trivial goal
to have and only 54 of all AAA projects
even make it from Pilot into production
in today's talk I will cover some
methodologies that I find to be really
really helpful in improving both
delivery and impact so let's start a
preparation for our journey into
production first there are some items
we'll need to cross off our checklists
so we need to make sure we find and
identify our starting points and your
starting point is the maturity of
machine learning adaptation in your
company
because that will have a lot of
influence on the complexity and length
of our journey to the Mountaintop so is
it a data-driven company when all
decision making is based on data and
analytics an AI driven company where the
main product is some artificial
intelligence capability did you already
make it to a successful proof of concept
based on machine learning or are you
already heavily heavily invested in
machine learning machine learning models
in production driving Revenue to the
company
So based on your starting point make
sure all stakeholders that you're
involved with are aligned in the
experimental mindset that is required
for data-driven development so back to
the journey analogy that is the pep talk
you have with your fellow Travelers when
you're getting started for the climb you
need to make sure all studies Journey
with the right mindset for the team
effort and many times this educational
step it does not come smoothly people
work with software developers with in no
way except the software developer saying
he's that he released a new web page and
he's only 97 confident that this page
will actually load what do you mean
you're not 100 confident well our
machine learning algorithms are just a
piece of software with a confidence
tagging tag paint into it so this stage
is really important it can be an offsite
with your stakeholders or presentation
with an open discussion whatever you can
in order to explain the experimental
Minds said how it differs from regular
software development and basically
because otherwise people tend to move
uncomfortably in their chairs if they
are asked to put a lot of funding into a
black box so the mystified explain how
you make sure you reduce the risk be
transparent in your day-to-day work and
gain organizational trusts
one more thing before we start a new
Journey we must check for the weather
forecast we definitely should mind the
weather because when it rains it falls
and today's weather is raining indeed
with Market leaders being
going through some cutoffs and layoffs
and companies are being asked not just
to show profit to show profit but not
only the promise of growth so basically
just the promise of growth is not good
enough we need to show profit and it
will take again the journey analogy if
you were walking on a really really nice
hike during spring time that same path
can get really really slippery when it
starts raining so we need to quickly
adjust our cores
so you may feel like that at the moment
with all that information regarding
layoffs and cutoffs but fear not set
your umbrellas and let's do this
so especially when it rains ever but
always and especially especially wind
trains we need to make sure we have an
impact so regardless if you're in a
management position feature owner data
scientist each in our own role can adapt
in the light of those guidelines in
order to improve our impact so basically
we want to balance between incremental
small improvements with lower risk in
and the big swings those are the huge
new features they have a lot of more
risk but additional promise into them so
in machine learning context incremental
can be
retrained the model you already have in
production with a bit more data tweak
with the loss a bit maybe tune your
hyper parameters and thresholds those
could be incremental improvements they
gain Improvement almost guaranteed to uh
to gain new improvements but they can
only take you so far the big swing can
be implementing a whole new architecture
a new model this is a new risky research
phase
and what we want to do we want to
balance the two so let's take a look and
in that image right here so there are
many ways to make it to the top we can
walk incremental step by step by foot or
we can take the big swing with the cable
car right here so basically incremental
is not always the safest way to go and
I'll explain why while the big swings
they tend to take longer time and they
require a larger effort compared to
incrementals where you always deliver
value faster a value some value it's
usually smaller the big swings are the
differentiators that's what
differentiate us from competition that's
the amazing new big feature that no
other competitor can achieve in time by
the time that we'll release it but
incremental in on the other hand may
miss our end goal because they can only
take us so far so we want to balance and
want to make sure we always plan to have
at least one big swing project that
we're working on
MVP mindset minimal viable product
mindset let me explain that with that
image right here so let's assume our end
goal what we want to release is a car
and it's a very large task so we break
down into stages but the problem with
this approach up here is that each of
those stages basically uh gain no value
to the end user so the user will have to
wait for a very very long while until
they get what they want so we may miss
the market opportunity or lose the
competition with the MVP mindset we make
sure each step each step has some value
and we ask ourselves how we can release
something even smaller that can create
some impacts but I call that mvp mindset
with end in mind because we need to make
sure we keep pushing toward that end
goal because our users they will simply
not stay satisfied with the scooter for
a long while if they are expecting a car
so make sure not to settle down for
incrementals only make sure you
eventually deliver the big swing the car
and in the context of machine learning
for example if your end goal is a
detection problem maybe only solving
localization first before you can really
classify well enough has an impact of
its own before you make it into a full
detection
okay so we're done with preparations and
we are now ready to hit the road
first we should not start any Journey
without a plan so plan your work and
work your plan if you're a project
manager feature owner Tech lead every
collaboration is really important and we
need to do it well let's say that that
distant mountain right here
um is our Target if this will remain our
only defined Target well I call that the
mountain of two vague two vague targets
because it's too far away poorly defined
and introduces many uncertainties and
during the climb you'll just get a sense
of
will never make it it's just so far away
when the target is too vague and too far
away we just miss the feeling of
progress and if that will remain our
only target then this guy right here he
will take the turn to the beach instead
of keep climbing and we don't want to do
that
so basically we must set visible targets
and I know it's been argued that you
cannot put time estimation on machine
learning research tasks they are to
explain there are two experimental and
you have so many unknowns but in my
experience
um those huge tasks are the ones you do
need to break down to smaller pieces and
for example your epic collaboration can
include an initial data exploration
phase literature review developing the
business metric model development
evaluation so on and so on so break it
down and that will basically reduce the
uncertainty of each of each stage and
gain that energizing sense of actual
progress
and um in order to really make sure we
progress with the visible targets and
not lose our course we need to make sure
we have a compass so we need to align
with the product manager on our business
goal really really early on get that
metric just right what is success and
how do we measure it
and now let's assume that we already
experimented a bit and are convinced
that this machine learning problem is
solvable and we by now have some basic
idea on how and what building blocks of
algorithms we need to develop so
basically we have the basic concept
for example preprocess block should come
first then we will do some object
detection final localization
classification then some decision block
so we have a basic concept with some
kind of a plan to progress but how we
make it into a working software what's
the next step
so this one that's for professional
hikers only okay I find this approach to
be very useful to keep focus and improve
progress and I call that the test driven
machine learning it's inspired by test
driven developments so basically first
you want to set your business metric and
it's not only the success criteria it's
not only definition it's actually coding
and write it down the function that will
evaluate a business metric this really
force you to understand what kind of
data you need in order to really be able
to calculate that then you want to
create the API of each block build a
pipeline each block right here you
should set inputs and outputs and you
want to be able to connect them so API
no content yet
and then build unit tests for each block
and evaluation metric of its own so
those unit tests they will initially
fail
um because
um those blocks they do not meet
performance criteria when you're only
just getting started but only at this
point where you actually built the full
pipeline all the moving parts are
connected right now and you have the the
metric to evaluate each now you can
invest into research and improve each
block and iterate and now that all
moving parts are connected you have a
way to measure each one and the full
pipeline this enables you to identify
release opportunities early so you could
iterate and improve and improve and
improve so you will identify release
opportunities reduce the uncertainty
regarding to where you stand compared to
your end goal
and in the context of validating new
product ideas it has been said that if
you're going to fail then fail fast and
we can adopt
for that in our research phase as well
and what do I mean by that we talked
earlier about the importance of success
criteria and the way to measure the
success or Compass but when you do that
every collaboration it's not only
important to set that acceptance
criteria that definition of done it's
also important to have a stop criteria
and what is that well basically many
researchers can find themselves are
really digging into some problem and
even a month of work being stuck with
their head against the wall before
realizing that is a wall right here we
hit the wall and we hit it a long time
ago but we just keep pushing and
insisting on that specific course of
action so basically we want we want to
make sure we have the right indicators
that will alarm Us in time that we are
about to hit the wall and that we hit
the wall and we should stop rethink and
reconsider our continued research and
it's really important that if you
actually hit that stop criteria and that
stop criteria could be a time limit for
the research combined with some
performance thresholds something like
that or anything else if you hit that
stock criteria and you made a decision
that you do not want to continue in that
path then document the reasons why why
was it it's successful because if you're
not document them then one of two things
may happen the first thing maybe you
will repeat the exact same mistake again
with the same circumstances somewhere in
the future the second thing that may
happen is that you will come across a
different problem different scenario
with different assumptions and you will
say no no we we've tried that approach
in the past and it didn't work but
basically everything changed that the
assumptions that cause this failure are
no longer valid and maybe that will be
the exact best course for you to take
but you just didn't record the failure
reasons so you can't tell so make sure
you document them to be able to get back
on track as soon as possible
and some additional tips how we can
boost our machine learning research with
agility is we don't only break down to
visible targets when we do that at the
collaboration we want to make sure that
the stories that we break that down into
are contained in a week of progress or
in a week's time of work and we don't
only want to work on them we want to
make sure that they're in some way
deliverable so make sure even in the
research phase you open a pull request
on a weekly basis yes even in the
research phase because
um well I'm not sure how many of you did
a code review for data scientists before
machine learning researcher but as a
computer vision researcher I was once
asked to do
um a chord review for a colleague when
he finished working on a very big new
feature and tens tens of new classes so
many new functions I had no part in the
design of This research and the research
of this feature so it's insane how can
you code review that you basically can't
so even during research breakdown into
smaller pieces that someone else can
really give you some feedback about
finding your bugs and wrong assumptions
earlier on and I'll give you a hint it
doesn't have to be a request into the
master Branch not at all it could be a
side branch that you open a pull request
to and gain that
um that progress of someone actually
reviewing it and don't just open that
for request and leave it at as it just
make sure you merge it because a pull
request that is open for more than two
weeks becomes unmanageable and
irrelevant so make sure it gets the
right attention and is being merged and
peer review is not only important in the
context of code but also about
assumptions and results so share those
with your peers and make sure you get
review on those as well so you will be
able to get a sense that you you keep
moving in the right direction so if
you're using scrum and Sprints and you
see the progress from one speed to the
other or if it's a kanban board where
you see your tickets flow forming
progress in verification done that's
energizing and gives you the sense that
you're in the right course and you're
getting there
um one more thing that I find to be
really important
um is basically data driven research and
what is that if we start a research with
insufficient data then we basically
build something or really unstable and
weak foundations
so um this following approach something
that I came up with in previous company
it took me a while to really get
everyone in the right mindset in order
to follow it through but basically let's
say
um all the teams in your company are
sitting down at the age and at the end
of each quarter planning the quarter
ahead
then only the algorithmic group should
at least that group should plan earlier
on so let's say in the middle of q1 you
should already have the plan for Q2 so
you can immediately start the data
collection and then cleaning the data
annotation that is required in order for
you to be able in Q2 to really start a
meaningful research and that can really
just reduce uncertainties in your
research improve that research make it
much more productive and just give you
that shorter cycle of research so that's
a test for the experimental mindset
adaptation in your company how well can
you plan the data collection ahead of
the research
and um
if you aim for example for this new
machine learning feature and you aim for
it to work in day one for all possible
users all possible scenarios anytime
anywhere you will have a hard time to
meet the quality requirements for all
that and be able to deliver some value
in a reasonable time what in MVP we ask
ourselves what is the minimal
proposition that we can release that
provides some value in our case we will
ask what is the smallest subset of data
to validate the research and gain impact
so basically
sit down with your product manager and
try to figure out what subsets of data
can you aim that first release to it
could be a different type of user groups
so for example the first release will
only aim for early adapter users the
second release then will the second
version the second version that you will
release will then aim for a larger group
of people of users or of scenarios it
could be different camera types it can
be different operating systems and so on
so basically you create Focus between
versions and you improve your ability to
actually have some value released to a
part of the users in a reasonable time
and especially imported in B2B but
always we need to make sure
um we do not do a full rollback and the
full rollback is the horrible scenario
where you already released the version
in production it's running this new
machine learning feature but it
misbehaves because of data shifts or
some unexpected scenario and you will
now need to roll back the entire version
not only this new feature everything
with all the new bug fixes and all the
new features and basically it cannot
happen you need to make sure that you
have a turn off for these new machine
learning feature this new model only so
we definitely always want to avoid a
full rollback of the entire version It's
costly it hurts the user trust
engagement and therefore we must always
strive to design a fallback for a
specific new machine learning feature to
allow us to disable just that feature
without affecting the whole version
and in B2B it might be done manually
just for this one specific user but
optimally you want to design an
automatic fallback based on a calculated
condition uh during the runtime so it
could be unreasonable predictions
exceeding runtime uh assumptions that
break and you can actually code it and
check in real time something like that
that you could automatically decide to
turn that new feature off and by doing
that you also it well it allows you to
continue and collect data for this new
feature and identify the source of the
issues and then improve
one more thing I really like are inner
releases I find those to really just
create shorter research Cycles into
production and what is an inner release
and in release says that you take now
this new machine learning functionality
and you make sure to make the plan of
how you fully integrated fully
integrated into a working software in
production it could be sitting with all
the teams involved the development team
the devops it's already integrated into
the databases integrated to everything
so we have an end-to-end working
software just don't influence the user
just yet okay so basically uh you do all
the calculation you store them in your
databases but you don't show anything
different to the user so that's really
can help you to start integration in
parallel to the research so while your
research may not yet hit the performance
requirements but you're getting there
you can already already starting to
integration and by the time you will be
finished with your research then only
just releasing new weights and working
with thresholds will not be that big of
a deal so that definitely helps you to
reduce risk create shorter research
Cycles you face the real world earlier
you gain organizational trust when
everyone are involved in the integration
and really understand what this feature
does you have the full integration and
basically you're putting the door to
really uh starting to have a feel of
real data and how this feature really
really Acts
so yay we are ready to release and now
what one stage of our journey is over
but another begins just before we
release well it's always important but
especially just before we release it's
important to align expectations imagine
that you were climbing that mountain for
a while and now you have that fantasy
about the amazing view that you will see
when you get there so align expectations
I'm a big believer in in a release note
so make sure you write down those
release notes and States
um the main impacts of this new machine
learning feature the improvements but
also the current models limitations and
if you have remaining open issues and
known bugs make sure you write those
down too so that will really gain trust
and everyone will know what to expect
and what not to expect
and once we are in production it's
really important for us to uh to
understand how we do a rollout so
basically we talked earlier about the
data subsets table that's a different
table data subsets they were addressing
different versions each version
um really want to make sure you do the
right product for the right subset of
users for example this table is
different this table is about the same
version being gradually released so it
could be one country after the other one
content continent after the other it
could be gradual increase of your
traffic either way make sure you have a
control group to compare to that your
dashboard and monitoring is ready and
that you store the data that you'll need
in order to get the feedback of how it
works in production identify issues
improve and basically get ready for the
next release
and when you're finally there in
production don't forget be an ml
Advocate and what do I mean by that
share analysis about
um about this amazing new feature just
raise awareness for this feature it's it
could be an email shared dashboard
whatever you can and celebrate the
success with a happy hour or something
like that it's just as important to
enjoy the success
so I really hope you enjoyed our journey
together and I wish you many successful
journeys of your own with happy into
production endings
um thank you so much
um please feel free to reach out via
LinkedIn I will be really happy to
continue discussion and get your
feedback about the talk and I hope to
see you all later today in my second
talk about classification for regression
a bit more technical thank you so much
thank you so much for being with us here
um there is a question
in your opinion in your opinion opinion
where should be the focus for in you
unexperienced team that is just getting
started well basically the most
important thing is for you to understand
your starting point so that was one of
the first slides right so the starting
point matters you need to understand
what type of company machine learning
adaptation phase you are currently at
let me get there sorry so many slides
so it will be really really different
based on the stage if it's a an
unexperienced team that is only facing
the first proof of concept or is it a
new team with the company already have
routines to regularly
um create releases into production
so if you already have another team
that's released into production
basically it's important to
um to study their methodologies what
works what to make sure that you can
replicate and where you can improve but
if it's your first proof of concept then
basically that phase of alignment with
your stakeholders about experimental
mindset is really important to make sure
how you can create those routines inside
your company to gain the data you need
in order to create healthier cycles of
research